Wir werden Geschichte schreiben
in der ganzen Schweiz!
Oder?
Wir schreiben Geschichte, Alter!
Na, Trainer? Ah!
Mega gut!
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge,
leises Stimmengewirr *
Dieser Film handelt von
einer brasilianischen Einwanderin,
die Schweizer Geschichte
schreiben will.
Viviane Obenauf ist Profiboxerin mit
Schweizer Lizenz und noch viel mehr:
Mutter auf High Heels,
leidenschaftliche Kellnerin,
gewiefte Unternehmerin, sozial
engagiert - ein Kämpferherz.
Sie gibt viel dafür,
ihren Traum leben zu können.
* Mundharmonikaklänge *
* Langgezogene Mundharmonika-
und Gitarrenklänge *
Im August 2018 hatte Viviane Obenauf
den Fight ihres Lebens.
Heilige Maria!
Natasha Jonas
versus Viviane Obenauf.
Ay, dios!
Sie gewinnt gegen die Engländerin
und Favoritin Natasha Jonas.
Jetzt habe ich sie voll getroffen.
Buff, buff! Jetzt! Buff!
Ich habe gesagt:
"Ich muss gewinnen."
Ich hatte keinen anderen Gedanken.
Nicht, um Geld zu verdienen, einzu-
kassieren und nach Hause zu gehen.
Ich musste gewinnen.
Ich hatte keine Angst
vor dieser Frau, niemals.
Und jetzt vor - buff! Rein! Hm!
Schau mal, hier! Ja!
Wow!
Sieg durch technisches K.o.!
Meine Familie ist so stolz.
Mein Papa, meine Mama unglaublich.
Mein Vater weinte,
meine Mutter auch.
Sie sind so glücklich und stolz,
dass ich diesen Weg gegangen bin.
Aber was mich richtig nervt,
sind die falschen Menschen.
Die, die nie an mich geglaubt haben,
die mich immer kritisiert haben.
Das ist mein Traum.
Ich sagte immer:
"Ich werde Boxerin, ich kann das."
Und jeder sagt:
"Du bist eine Spinnerin."
Und dann hat es funktioniert. Wow!
Warum es plötzlich funktioniert?
Ich habe nicht aufgegeben.
Der Wille ist noch grösser, wenn
die Leute nicht an dich glauben.
Ich zeig es dir, ich zeig es dir!
Auf jeden Fall!
Bam!
* Sie lacht. *
Drei Wochen
sind seit diesem Kampf vergangen.
Obenauf wartet jetzt
auf die Einladung zur Revanche.
So ist es im Profiboxen üblich.
Ich bin sicher, dass sie
ihren Titel wieder haben möchte.
Aber ich habe keine Angst.
Warum sollte ich
vor einer Frau Angst haben?
Ich habe Angst, arm zu sein,
krank zu werden,
kein Dach über dem Kopf zu haben.
Davor habe ich Angst,
aber nicht vor einer Frau.
Seit Obenauf vor vier Jahren
vom Olympischen Boxen -
auch Amateurboxen genannt -
zum Profiboxen gewechselt hat,
kann sie mit ihren schnellen Fäusten
auch Geld verdienen.
Als alleinerziehende Mutter
nicht ganz unwichtig.
Der Kampf war gut,
Mama hat gewonnen.
Viel Geld bekommen.
Nicht viel Geld, aber ein bisschen
Geld hat Mama verdient.
Endlich, nicht? Und jetzt
geht das Leben positiv nach oben.
Ja, ich freue mich sehr.
Noch ein bisschen essen. Das ist gar
nichts. Du hast gar nichts gegessen.
Mindestens die Hälfte, okay?
Sonst bleibst du bis morgen sitzen.
6'000 Euro brachte die 31-Jährige
von England nach Hause.
Nach Hause an den Brienzersee,
zu Calvin, ihrem 7-jährigen Sohn.
Oje, oje, oje!
Du hast heute zu wenig gegessen.
Mit rund vier Kämpfen pro Jahr,
als Frau, in der Schweiz,
ist es praktisch unmöglich,
vom Boxsport leben zu können.
Vivane Obenauf
hat drei verschiedene Jobs,
kümmert sich mit ihrem Ex-Mann
zusammen um den Sohn
und trainiert nebenbei
für die grossen Kämpfe.
Salü!
- Ist heute in stressiger Tag?
Nein, ich mache das ...
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass ich deswegen Stress habe.
Ich kann damit gut umgehen.
Man muss etwas machen,
dann schafft man etwas im Leben.
Das hat mein Vater mir beigebracht:
"Willst du etwas erreichen,
dann geh arbeiten!"
"Willst du, dass die Leute dich
mögen, zahl pünktlich die Rechnung,
sonst bist du einfach niemand."
Das ist so, das ist wahr.
Und so rennt sie täglich - notabene
in High Heels - vom Job, zum Kind,
zum Training -
um ihren Traum
vom Boxen leben zu können.
Welcome to my villa.
Achtung, Stufe!
Seit zwei Jahren besitzt sie
in Interlaken ihr eigenes Gym.
Angefangen hat alles vor sieben
Jahren, nach der Geburt ihres Sohnes.
Als ich schwanger war ...
Sehr jung, mit 25.
Ich habe fast 30 kg zugenommen.
Ich war überglücklich, ich durfte
alles essen, was ich wollte.
Das war schön.
Danach gab es die Konsequenzen.
Ich war ein bisschen dick.
Es ist schon ein Schock
für viele Mütter.
Was passiert mit unserem Körper
in einer Schwangerschaft?
Los! Ja, ja!
Um die Pfunde wieder loszuwerden,
fing sie an zu boxen.
Und konnte nicht mehr aufhören.
Nach zwei Monaten wollte sie
bereits einen Wettkampf bestreiten.
Nach einem Jahr, mit 26, habe ich
die Schweizer Meisterschaft gemacht
und ich habe gewonnen.
Ich habe mit Boxerinnen geboxt,
die schon seit acht, neun Jahren
geboxt haben.
Ja, das war geil.
Es war unglaublich.
Und Sieg!
Als Profiboxerin hat Viviane Obenauf
bisher 17 Kämpfe bestritten
und nur vier davon verloren.
Nach dem Erfolg in England
hofft sie nun auf weitere
attraktive Kampfangebote,
sodass ihr Marktwert in der Boxwelt
weiter steigt.
* Sie singt mit dem Autoradio mit. *
So.
... und für Sie
auch noch einen Schluck.
Das haben Sie schon verdient.
- (Mann) Ja.
Doch so steil
ihre Boxkarriere auch sein mag:
Alles auf diese eine Karte zu setzen,
wäre der Brasilianerin zu waghalsig.
In Bern arbeitet sie 50 % im Service.
Es ist anstrengend,
macht müde, aber ...
Ah ... Dieser Gedanke, dass wir
nur jetzt hier sind, in dieser Zeit.
Vielleicht boxe ich
nur noch fünf Jahre,
dann muss ich jetzt wirklich
richtig Gas geben.
Ich denke, dieser Lohn im Service
ist für mich wichtig.
Ich habe eine Pizza bestellt.
Ich habe extra geschrieben:
extra scharf.
Die Leute, die ich kenne,
sind mir alle ganz nah.
Boxen
ist auf der anderen Strassenseite.
Mein Manager ist hier. Es ist gut,
es macht Spass. Nicht, Chef?
* Dumpfe, gezupfte Celloklänge *
Im Boxkeller
gegenüber dem Restaurant
trainiert Obenauf jeweils
vor einem grossen Kampf.
Hier glaubt man an sie.
Wobei: Mit dem Sieg in England hat
selbst ihr Manager nicht gerechnet.
Viviane ist eine sehr engagierte
Boxerin, eine kämpferische Frau.
Und, äh ...
Sie hat vermutlich
keine sehr filigrane Technik.
Aber wegen ihres Kampfwillens
und weil sie nach dem Motto
"Auf los geht's los!"
zur Sache ging, konnte sie
die Gegner in Bedrängnis bringen.
Das überraschte auch uns.
Gabor Vetö ist Ex-Profiboxer
und Obenaufs Trainer.
Ein langer Tag.
Er würde sie lieber
im Boxkeller antreffen als hier.
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut, danke. Dir auch.
Ein Monat jetzt.
- Ja.
Ein Monat - und ich war
bis jetzt noch nicht im Training.
Du musst langsam
wieder anfangen zu trainieren.
Ja, jetzt ...
Du musst
wieder regelmässig trainieren.
Trainieren, trainieren. Ja.
Locker Alter, locker!
- Ich bin locker.
Für ihren Optimismus
ist Obenauf bekannt.
Ist Viviane jetzt im Moment fit?
Nein, sie ist nicht fit.
Meiner Meinung nach
war sie noch nie richtig fit.
Weil, halt ...
Sie ist hauptberuflich
keine Boxerin.
Sie arbeitet nebenbei, hat
eine eigene Boxschule und ein Kind.
(Seufzend) Ha, buff!
* Sie atmet schwer aus. *
Finito!
Würde sie öfter trainieren,
wäre sportlich mehr möglich,
so der Trainer.
Doch die Wahlschweizerin
lässt sich nicht gerne reinreden.
In Brasilien aufgewachsen, hat sie
mit 21 eine Reise nach Europa gemacht
und in Basel
ihren Ex-Mann kennengelernt.
Ihre Familie hatte sich einen
anderen Weg für sie vorgestellt.
Ja, meine Familie ...
Sie ist gut gebildet.
Viele meiner Cousins, Cousinen oder
Tanten sind Anwälte oder Ingenieure.
Meine Schwester ist Lehrerin.
Mein Bruder wollte nicht zur Uni.
Ich war auch ein Jahr an der Uni,
das ging nicht.
Ich war sehr traurig. Ich wollte
eigentlich Medizinerin werden.
Ich wollte
meinen Vater glücklich machen.
Das war nichts für mich.
Aber ich bin so.
Ich kann nicht Sachen machen,
um anderen Leuten zu gefallen.
Ich war schon als Kind so.
Ich muss Freude haben.
Wenn ich keine Freude habe,
dann laufe ich einfach davon.
Das ist meine Schwäche,
kann man sagen.
Der Schweiz
ist sie noch nicht davongelaufen.
Seit zehn Jahren
ist hier ihre neue Heimat.
Boah! Es gefällt mir alles.
Ich will hier leben und wohnen.
Das System ist gut so.
Die Schweizer sind anders,
aber das System funktioniert.
Anders in Brasilien.
Die Armut, die in gewissen Regionen
herrscht, erträgt Obenauf nicht.
Deshalb sammelt sie
in der Garage eines Ferienhauses
gebrauchte Kinderkleider
und bringt sie einmal im Jahr
bedürftigen Familien
in ihrer alten Heimatstadt.
Hier ist schon
ein bisschen ein Chaos.
Armut gab es immer.
Viele machen einfach die Augen zu.
Wenn man dort ist,
hat man nicht viele Möglichkeiten,
den Leuten zu helfen.
Und wenn man dort lebt,
findet man alles so normal.
Man sieht das ganz anders,
als wenn man hier ist.
Hey, wenn ich das den Kindern gebe,
weisst du, wie die sich freuen?
Ihr habt keine Ahnung.
Das ist schön.
Ich freue mich, wenn ich das mache.
Immer, immer.
Um sich die Reisen nach Brasilien
leisten zu können,
putzt und betreut sie solche
Ferienhäuser - ein weiterer Job.
* Mundartsong "O79" von Lo & Leduc *
# ... stimme.
Die Profiboxerin
ist sich für nichts zu schade.
Abends gibt sie fast täglich
Trainings in ihrem eigenen Boxlokal.
Ich probiere immer,
alles ganz schön sauber zu lassen.
Denn das ist mein Geschäft.
Und darauf bin ich so stolz!
Immer! Mein Stolz!
Stolz auch auf einen Sport,
bei dem sich zwei Menschen mit
den Fäusten die Köpfe einschlagen.
Was gefällt dir an diesem Sport,
bei dem es doch recht hart
zu und her geht?
Aggressiv, ja.
Die Herausforderung.
Und, ja, das Kampfgefühl.
Es ist keine Schlägerei,
das geht nicht.
Wenn man einfach schlägt,
bekommt man das zurück.
Ein Kampf, ein Fight -
ein gutes Gefühl.
Wie ein Tiger! Wie Tiere  -
das sind wir Menschen sowieso.
Hopp, hopp, hopp! Tschau!
Wie geht's?
* Sie begrüssen sich gegenseitig. *
Heute gibt es kein Seilspringen,
sondern Reifenspringen.
Ihre Begeisterung
für den Kampfsport steckt an -
v.a. auch Mädchen und Frauen, die den
Grossteil ihrer Kundschaft ausmachen.
Wir machen ein Video
für unsere Fans auf Instagram!
Wir geben Gas! Wir geben nicht auf!
Komm, Frau Carmen! Komm!
Nicht schlafen!
Komm, nicht aufgeben!
- (Frau) Ich kann nicht.
Nicht so denken: "Ich kann nicht."
"Ich kann das, ich will das!"
1 Min. Pause!
Wasser trinken nicht vergessen!
C'mon meine Blümchen!
Ich muss streng sein. Das hat mich
mein Trainer in Berlin gelernt.
Aber sie mögen das,
sonst wären sie nicht hier.
Ich bin nett und lieb,
aber trainieren muss man seriös.
Sobald sie eine Einladung
zur Revanche in England erhalte,
werde auch sie wieder
mit seriösem Training beginnen.
Doch Wochen und Monate vergehen
und keine Einladung trifft ein.
Bis im November
dann plötzlich alles anders kommt:
Viviane Obenauf
hat ein Kampfangebot erhalten.
Nicht gegen die Engländerin
Natasha Jonas soll sie boxen,
sondern in Paris die vierfache
Meisterin im Superfedergewicht
der International Boxing Federation
herausfordern.
Was denkst du über den Kampf?
Ist das ein guter Kampf?
Es ist das Beste,
was mir im Moment passieren konnte.
Es ist der Beweis, das ganz
gute Angebote für mich da sind.
IBF ist der wichtigste Verband
im Boxen, der älteste auch.
Ich bin sehr stolz,
dass sie zu mir kommen.
Sie werden
eine grosse Überraschung haben
und sie wollen
einen harten Kampf sehen.
Deshalb setzen sie zwei wilde Frauen
in den Boxring, das ist der Grund.
Und raus! Zack, zack ganz locker!
Und dann 'ne Harte.
Dann explodierst du.
Das dauert zu lange.
Für die letzten Tage
vor dem Showdown
lässt sie ihren ehemaligen
Trainer aus Berlin einfliegen.
Obenauf hat rund einen Monat
intensive Vorbereitung hinter sich.
Physisch ist sie gut drauf.
Die Psyche ist ihre grosse Stärke.
Wir müssen noch die eine oder andere
technische Variante erarbeiten,
um die Gegnerin zu überraschen.
Kriegen wir das hin, bin ich
optimistisch, aber es wird schwer.
Hast du Angst vor ihr?
- Nein, ich habe keine Angst.
Ich habe Angst,
wenn mein Sohn 40 °C Fieber hat,
aber nicht vor einer Sportlerin,
die im Ring steht wie ich.
Ich habe keine Angst,
aber ich habe Respekt.
Sie ist wild wie ich
und wir sind irgendwie gleich.
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
Das ist sie - ihre Gegnerin,
die Französin Maiva Hamadouche.
Nummer 1 auf der Weltrangliste
von Boxing Record.
Am Morgen des Fights
müssen beide zum Wiegen antreten.
Eine gewisse Obergrenze
darf nicht überschritten werden.
Muy bien.
- Wie viel?
Que lo mires.
59,9 kg.
Si, 59.98.
Warte mal,
ich muss mich orientieren.
Hier!
Rechts, folgt mir!
Der Kampf findet erst am Abend statt.
Die Profiboxerin
hat ihre eigene Strategie,
wie sie mit dem Druck umgeht.
Nur im Hotel zu sitzen
und die Boxer zu sehen
und den ganzen Zirkus mitzukriegen,
das mag ich gar nicht.
Ich will weg von diesen Leuten sein.
Frische Luft,
nicht so viel nachdenken.
Ich muss heute sowieso boxen,
ich kann nicht davonlaufen.
Dann ...
Abschalten ist gut.
Merci beaucoup!
Ich bin fast 4 kg schwerer als sie.
Ich muss das positiv sehen.
Das bedeutet, ich bin ... ja ...
Mein Punch
sollte stärker sein als ihrer.
Ich hoffe es. Das muss sein!
Um Gottes Willen!
Die Gedanken kreisen -
trotz Ablenkung - ums Boxen
und um ihren Sohn Calvin,
der sich vor jedem Kampf
Sorgen um seine Mami macht.
Ende November letzten Jahres
war ein Boxkampf,
bei dem ich mich sehr verletzte.
Seitdem ist er
ein bisschen skeptisch geworden.
Seine letzten Worte gestern waren:
"Mama, du darfst nicht verlieren,
sonst bin ich sauer auf dich!"
Ich sagte: "Ja okay,
Mama macht das nicht."
Ich darf nicht verlieren.
Auch wegen ihm.
* Surren *
- Wow!
Tschüss aus Paris!
Eiffelturm, c'est tres joli!
* Lockere Akkordeonmusik *
Hallo, Calvin!
In 3 Std. ist mein Kampf, okay?
Ja. Betest du für Mami?
Oh, sch...
Danke, danke.
Ganz fest an Mami denken! Okay.
Tschüss, tschüss.
Oh, mein Herz!
* Sie seufzt. *
* Stimmengewirr, verzerrte Klänge *
* Rhythmische Musik *
Schau mal, Schweiz!
Die letzten Stunden bis zum Kampf
verbringen Obenauf und ihr Team
in der Garderobe.
Beim Bandagieren
sind ein Teammitglied der Gegnerin
und ein Vertreter des Boxverbandes
dabei.
Korrekt?
- Warum wird das so genau beobachtet?
Weil man da je nachdem
etwas reintun könnte
oder weil man die Masse
nicht einhält.
Es gibt da schon Möglichkeiten.
Hast du nie Angst,
dass deinem Körper etwas passiert?
Nein, jeder Sport hat sein Risiko.
* Dynamische Musik *
Ich denke, das ist normal.
Fussballspieler sind öfter verletzt
als wir Boxer.
Try not to get on the ground, okay?
Matchmaker Joe Forbes
interessiert weniger das Verletzungs-
als das finanzielle Risiko
bei einem solchen Kampf.
No money, no honey, yes Baby Joe?
* Er lacht. *
I know what you mean.
Ich werde alles geben, auf jeden
Fall, man kann mich nicht kaufen.
Das ist so. Das sage ich immer, ich
bin nicht wegen des Geldes hier.
Das Geld ist etwas Schönes,
aber man boxt nicht wegen Geld.
Das ist für mich Prostitution.
(Stadionsprecher) Le championnat
du monde de boxe feminine ...
* Spannende Musik *
First choice, Viviane.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
(Stadionsprecher) C'est
une Bresilienne de naissance ...
qui boxe
sous les couleurs helvetiques ...
On accueille Viviane Obenauf!
* Spannende Musik, Applaus *
* Glocke *
Premiere reprise,
allez, on les encourage!
Le bruit, l'ambiance.
He, tout le monde! Tout le monde!
* Applaus, Pfiffe *
* Verschiedene Kommentatoren
sprechen durcheinander. *
Du hast noch Reserven.
(Originalkommentar) Un impose,
un physique, un impose, regardez ca!
Oui, oui, clairement,
elle l'a touche.
Es fängt gut an. Die Fäuste fliegen.
Viviane Obenauf kämpft mutig drauflos
und steckt tapfer ein.
* Glocke *
Doch nach der fünften Runde
gibt sie plötzlich auf.
(Unverständliche Speaker-Ansage)
Hamadouche gewinnt den Weltmeister-
titel des IBF zum fünften Mal.
* Schwere Musik *
Schweiz, I'm sorry. Tut mir leid.
Nächstes Mal mach ich's besser.
Es geht gut. Ich bin nicht traurig,
nicht enttäuscht.
Aber - es ist gut, wenn man
die Grenzen spürt und man merkt,
dass es vielleicht
gefährlich werden kann.
Die Gesundheit
kommt an erster Stelle.
Ich glaube, das ist gebrochen.
In der vierten Runde habe ich ge-
dacht, ich kann nicht mehr schlagen.
* Sie hustet. *
Darum sagte ich ...
Später wurde bestätigt:
Obenauf hat sich in der vierten Runde
zwei Finger gebrochen.
Du hast gekämpft wie ein Löwe.
- Danke.
Wir müssen ...
- Ich habe dich enttäuscht.
Nein, du hast mich nicht enttäuscht,
aber wir müssen klüger kämpfen.
Ja, ich habe verloren,
aber das ist nicht schlimm.
In der sechsten Runde
haben sie abgebrochen.
Mein Finger ist gebrochen.
Ja, aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Ich bin trotzdem glücklich.
Ich habe nicht geweint.
Jürg, wir schreiben
ein anderes Mal Geschichte.
Wir schreiben
Mit nur einer Faust lässt sich
keine Schweizer Geschichte schreiben.
Doch die Kämpfernatur
wird weiter boxen -
nach kurzer Verschnaufpause
wieder mit beiden Fäusten.